We have a woman who has personally changed my life
and many others.
I'm in a long line of people who've been truly affected
by this human being.
A Drew Gooder through and through
and an elementary school teacher,
who I surprised earlier in the week in Dallas.
It's Madame Patricia Byrd is here.
(crowd cheers)
Patricia, take it away.
Express, ask your question.
The floor is yours.
Thank you so very much.
Welcome.
It's my pleasure to be here.
Little do you know, Chip and Joanna,
that you are my friends
in my head.
(everyone laughs)
The design of my home, both interior and exterior
reflects some of your design elements.
I have fashioned my Lawrence, my husband of 43 years,
into a little Chip.
(Joanna laughs)
Yes!
Hey, hey, hey.
You heard it, Lawrence.
In terms of when I have a vision, a desire, an idea,
he just grabs the tools and say, "let's just get after it."
Let's go.
It's demo day.
Woo, woo, woo, woo!
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, we accept it.
(crowd cheers)
My question for the two of you is this,
how do you manage with all that is your lives
to keep each other
priority on the front burner
first in your lives
above all else, above all others?
Wow.
Yeah.
That's beautiful.
Yo, you ready to rock?
That's a hard act follow right there.
I think we should be asking you that same question.
I know.
Forget us.
I say, after 18 years, bottom line for us,
I'll keep my portion of it simple,
it's just, we sincerely care and appreciate one another.
And make no mistake about it,
if something complicated were to come between Jo and I,
we would give all of this up in a heartbeat
to make sure that Jo and I end this race together
on a porch somewhere, reminiscing about the good old days.
Hopefully that's helpful.
What do you say, Jo?
For us, we're always going back to that foundation
and saying, does it need to be reworked?
Is there anything that we need to shore up a little bit,
but that's like a daily thing, it's maintenance.
This isn't a once a year,
February 14th, let's show each other we love you.
It's maintenance.
It's just like anything that you want,
you gotta work for it.
You don't just say, this is great,
and it's gonna stay great.
You have to work at it,
you have to push for those date nights.
You have to push for those coffee dates in the morning
just by the sofa by the fireplace.
Like whatever that is.
Patricia, before you take off,
I do wanna bless you with one quick thing.
Please do.
I have just felt overwhelmed by not only your presence,
but just your, you know, your energy.
You are just a strong, beautiful woman,
and I'm so thankful that you're here today.
But Jo and I would like to give you
and your husband $10,000.
And we're gonna give that to you today,
and you can spend it like a drunken sailor
or you can give it away
or you can contribute it to some foundation,
but we just wanted to bless you with that
before you took off.
God bless.
Oh my god.
(crowd cheers)
(crowd applauds)
10,000, ladies and gentlemen.
Come on, let's go!
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
(upbeat bright music)